Take what may be the most important invention of modern times:
programmable computers.
Now, the standard story is that computers descend from military technology,
since many of the early computers were designed specifically
to crack wartime codes or calculate rocket trajectories.
But in fact, the origins of the modern computer
are much more playful,
even musical,
than you might imagine.
The idea behind the flute,
of just pushing air through tubes to make a sound,
was eventually modified to create the first organ
more than 2,000 years ago.
Someone came up with the brilliant idea of triggering sounds
by pressing small levers with our fingers,
inventing the first musical keyboard.
Now, keyboards evolved from organs to clavichords to harpsichords
to the piano,
until the middle of the 19th century,
when a bunch of inventors finally hit on the idea
of using a keyboard to trigger not sounds but letters.
In fact, the very first typewriter
was originally called "the writing harpsichord."
Flutes and music led to even more powerful breakthroughs.
About a thousand years ago,
at the height of the Islamic Renaissance,
three brothers in Baghdad designed a device
that was an automated organ.
They called it "the instrument that plays itself."
Now, the instrument was basically a giant music box.
The organ could be trained to play various songs by using instructions
encoded by placing pins on a rotating cylinder.
And if you wanted the machine to play a different song,
you just swapped a new cylinder in with a different code on it.
This instrument was the first of its kind.
It was programmable.
Now, conceptually, this was a massive leap forward.
The whole idea of hardware and software
becomes thinkable for the first time with this invention.
And that incredibly powerful concept
didn't come to us as an instrument of war or of conquest,
or necessity at all.
It came from the strange delight of watching a machine play music.
In fact, the idea of programmable machines
was exclusively kept alive by music for about 700 years.
In the 1700s, music-making machines
became the playthings of the Parisian elite.
Showmen used the same coded cylinders
to control the physical movements of what were called automata,
an early kind of robot.
One of the most famous of those robots
was, you guessed it, an automated flute player
designed by a brilliant French inventor
named Jacques de Vaucanson.
And as de Vaucanson was designing his robot musician,
he had another idea.
If you could program a machine to make pleasing sounds,
why not program it to weave delightful patterns of color out of cloth?
Instead of using the pins of the cylinder to represent musical notes,
they would represent threads with different colors.
If you wanted a new pattern for your fabric,
you just programmed a new cylinder.
This was the first programmable loom.
Now, the cylinders were too expensive and time-consuming to make,
but a half century later,
another French inventor named Jacquard
hit upon the brilliant idea of using paper-punched cards
instead of metal cylinders.
Paper turned out to be much cheaper and more flexible
as a way of programming the device.
That punch card system inspired Victorian inventor Charles Babbage
to create his analytical engine,
the first true programmable computer
ever designed.
And punch cards were used by computer programmers
as late as the 1970s.
So ask yourself this question:
what really made the modern computer possible?
Yes, the military involvement is an important part of the story,
but inventing a computer also required other building blocks:
music boxes,
toy robot flute players,
harpsichord keyboards,
colorful patterns woven into fabric,
and that's just a small part of the story.
There's a long list of world-changing ideas and technologies
that came out of play:
public museums, rubber,
probability theory, the insurance business
and many more.
Necessity isn't always the mother of invention.
The playful state of mind is fundamentally exploratory,
seeking out new possibilities in the world around us.
And that seeking is why so many experiences
that started with simple delight and amusement
eventually led us to profound breakthroughs.
Now, I think this has implications for how we teach kids in school
and how we encourage innovation in our workspaces,
but thinking about play and delight this way
also helps us detect what's coming next.
Think about it: if you were sitting there in 1750
trying to figure out the big changes coming to society
in the 19th, the 20th centuries,
automated machines, computers,
artificial intelligence,
a programmable flute
entertaining the Parisian elite
would have been as powerful a clue as anything else at the time.
It seemed like an amusement at best,
not useful in any serious way,
but it turned out to be the beginning of a tech revolution
that would change the world.
You'll find the future
wherever people are having the most fun.